il y un an emmanuel macron descendez les
champs elysées tout sourire à bord d'un
véhicule militaire
défilé des troupes hommage aux soldats
une célébration dans la peau d'un
président
plutôt détendu aujourd'hui le contexte
est bien différent crise sanitaire
économique
le chef de l'état a choisi cette fois ci
de renouer avec la tradition de
l'interview du 14 juillet pour tenter de
répondre aux nombreuses inquiétudes des
français
il y a quelques jours les grandes lignes
de l'acte 2 du quinquennat ont
d'ailleurs été annoncé sur twitter
ensemble nous traçons les contours de ce
nouveau chemin qui sera centré sur la
reconstruction économique social
environnemental et culturel de notre
pays
avec cette interview emmanuel macron
ravive une vieille tradition
présidentielle initiée par valéry
giscard d'estaing en 1978 lors d'une
garden party à l'elysée
un exercice que l'ancien chef d'état va
répéter durant tout son septennat sans
successeur françois mitterrand va lui
aussi se prêter au jeu des
questions-réponses bicentenaire de la
révolution française lutte contre le
chômage est de développement immigration
autant de sujets abordés par le
socialiste au cours des douze entretiens
accordés entre 1982 et 1993
de son côté jacques chirac va s'emparer
de ce rendez-vous avec le sens de la
formule
quand je me suis aperçu du chiffre
exorbitant que l'on imputé au titre de
ses voyages privés lors de mon mandat
ce n'est pas que ces sommes se dégonfle
séquelles fuite
il n'y a pas de différend entre le
ministre des finances nicolas sarkozy et
moi
pour une raison simple c'est que
notamment s'agissant de la dépense je
décide il exécute arrivée au pouvoir en
2007 nicolas sarkozy va supprimer ce
rituel remis plus tard au goût du jour
par françois hollande en 2016
le président socialiste se livrent une
dernière fois à l'exercice et en profite
pour critiquer les ambitions
présidentielles de celui qui était alors
son ministre de l'économie
un certain emmanuel macron il ya des
règles la solidarité l'esprit d'équipé
la nécessité de servir jusqu'au bout
dans un gouvernement il n'y a pas de
démarche personnelle encore moins de
démarche présidentielle
ce jour de fête nationale emmanuel
macron va donc renouer avec cette
entrevue annuel il sera interrogé en
direct par deux journalistes 45 minutes
pour tenter de convaincre les français à
deux ans de la prochaine présidentielle